So, let's say we have a problem that we know to be an NP
but we're not sure if it is contained in P or not.
In that case, there is actually only two things that could be true
so either that problem is actually NP but we missed it
so we simply haven't looked hard enough to find a good algorithm for it
or that's the other possibility the problem is only contained in NP.
So, no matter how hard we look, we will never find a polynomial time algorithm for it.
The cool thing is that for some problems we know that they are closely related enough
so that it's actually sufficient to decide this question here
if we missed a polynomial time algorithm or if we just have no chance.
It's actually sufficient to decide this question for only one of the problems.
So for vertex cover, independent set, and clique, in the last unit,
we found out that those problems were closely related.
So, let's just do a little quiz to see if you remember how these problems were related to each other.
So, let's assume we found a polynomial time algorithm for vertex cover.
In that case, we would know for sure that vertex cover is contained in P.
So what will be the case for independent set and clique?
Would we also know these problems to be in P
or would it not be possible to make such a statement?